meg welcome to camp et thank you with
our buddies yeah we have an owl between
us I know
hello I asked you right before this was
like are you an animal lover like like
something I hope you love step shirtless
I'm allergic to like all animals how did
you ever go to summer camp um I did but
it was a gymnastics and cheerleading
camp so it wasn't really the regular
style it was for like a skill you had
some like practice to do yeah and I had
to clean all the gyms too so I could go
to the camp because like that was the
only way cause it's ly really expensive
right
so between I was cleaning I didn't get
to like do the activities and stuff
what's your favorite summer memory this
is always the first memory that pops in
my head and it's not even that funny or
like great but one time I was a jumping
on a track a trampoline and I was
laughing so hard and then I peed myself
and like I think I was like I was old
though I was like 12 and it's just I
must've been having a really good time
and I don't know why that's the thing
that always pops in my head you get to
see a lot of your fellow creators on the
Reg like or is it like stuff like VidCon
where you finally get to like rub elbows
with them well it depends so a lot of
them are international so VidCon it's
like the time when you're like we love
friends that hasn't seen you in so long
that's great cuz all of us or honestly
kind of is he doing like these crazy
random stuff so we're okay with just
seeing each other at the conventions and
that being are like catching up where we
left off and I was like that we're home
yeah and everyone's I feel like it's
kind of on the same page about that
stuff for the most part that's nice
that's awesome it's actually my first
time at VidCon how many I know I know so
far so good
how many think comes have you done - so
this is my third the first one I went to
was I think I just moved to LA I hadn't
been here too long but it was so great
and I was just like I'm coming in and
ever since it's been it's changed so
much like things would get bigger every
year so I'm like I'm gonna keep coming
and see what happens
you're busy like you have so much to
talk about a big console I'm glad you're
here you're in trolls oh yes so I did a
little cameo in trolls I say hi that
means somebody at that studio is
watching your videos all that voice
would really work as a troll yeah well
thanks for coming to hang out come back
next summer
are you excited wait for trolls and
we'll be watching on all your stuff on
YouTube yeah well thanks so much for
having me